ce
église du 20e siècle
dans les années 1930 de nombreuses
églises sont construites ou
reconstruites un peu partout dans l'île
cet élan se poursuit jusqu'au milieu du
xxème siècle achevé en 1858 l'église de
sainte-anne fait l'objet d'importants
travaux entre 1935 et 1947 trouvant son
inspiration dans des revues sur l'art
maroc
le père d'aubaine berger dirige les
travaux aidés de quelques habitants et
des enfants du catéchisme
il construit un nouveau clocher et la
chapelle sainte thérèse
c'est ici que se déroule quelques années
plus tard la cérémonie de mariage du
célèbre film de françois truffaut la
sirène du mississipi
on assiste dans les années 1930 1 re au
niveau de l'architecturé religieuse à la
zone bleue tout comme l' architecture
public
elle adopte les canons esthétiques du
style alors en vigueur en europe l'art
de lecteurs l'église notre dame des
neiges à cilaos en est l'un des plus
beaux exemples
elle reprend en effet dans ses moindres
détails les caractéristiques de ce style
des lignes pures une géométrisation des
formes et une grande symétrie l'église
de la bretagne est inauguré en 1967 le
côté brutalise de sa façade de pierre
sang nouveau en béton ses lignes sobres
tour reflètent ici last éthique des
années 60
surmontée de poutrelles poser en biais
la nef de cette église hal est inondé de
lumière grâce à sa façade ouest
entièrement composé de vitraux réalisés
par guy lefebvre